So it's another day. And another embarrassing
failure for the Trump administration. This
time it's Donald Trump's nominee to
replace his former secretary of defense, Jim
Mattis, who has bailed out and wants no part
of working for the Trump administration. Donald
Trump had nominated a guy named Patrick Shanahan
to fill the position and Shanahan had been
the acting secretary of defense since Jim
Madis left because he wanted no part of the
Trump administration. And before I go any
further, this is a serious position. I mean,
I don't think I should have to say this, but
this is a position that should be filled and
filled with a responsible, competent, qualified
adult. And Shanahan has announced that he
is resigning as allegations that he punched
his ex wife in the stomach, have extended
an FBI background check into Shanahan. Shanahan
has denied punching his wife in the stomach,
says his wife actually is the one who started
the fight. And ultimately his wife is the
one who was arrested and charged with domestic
violence.
And this entire incident overlaps with or
is connected to a fight that supposedly started
because of a briefcase. Uh, uh, the contents
of which Shanahan would keep in a closet near
their bathroom. We don't need to go into all
of the details, but this is off the wall.
Bonkers family drama and in general Shanahan's
family life is a pretty big mess. His son,
when 17 years old hit his mother with a baseball
bat, she was in the hospital because of its
Shanahan, flew from Seattle to Florida and
stayed at a hotel with his son until his son
eventually turned himself in. I mean, it's
truly horrible stuff, a lot of different views
as to what is the exact truth about this.
But ultimately this has led to Shanahan resigning
and Donald Trump following up by withdrawing
Shanahan's nomination. And once again, this
gets back to the same issue that has been
plaguing the Trump administration.
If the Trump administration took brat background
checks more seriously and did their own so
called extreme vetting before the FBI gets
into all of this, it would save everyone a
lot of public embarrassment. It would save
the Trump administration a lot of wasted time
in nominating and then withdrawing nominations
for people who are entangled in all sorts
of personal messages. So this is one of those
cases though where Trump's embarrassment and
failure to get his top pick into a position
might actually result in getting somebody
even worse on the job. Donald Trump has now
named mark the secretary of the army to be
Acting Secretary of defense. We don't know
whether he will be Trump's eventual nominee
for permanent secretary of defense, but what
we do know is that Esper is a total military
industrial complex guy. He's a former executive
at Raytheon, one of the biggest contractors,
a defense contractors in the country, although
it's not like Shanahan wasn't connected to
the military industrial complex up maybe slightly
less ominously Shanahan worked for Boeing
for 30 years.
But for me, this story is a reminder, yes,
of Trump's constant failures that are plaguing
his administration, but also of the fact that
our government is just riddled with every
kind of corporate rater and plutocrat and
Kleptocrat and corporatist and the like. And
we just don't have nearly enough of the right
types of people representing us and acting
on our behalf. We don't even know at this
point, as I said, whether Mark Esper will
eventually be Trump's pick for permanent secretary
of defense. He's just now acting secretary
of defense. And once again, the whole process
starts over again. But the bottom line here
is number one, we have way too many of these
military industrial complex corporate rate
or types involved in government in the same
way that we have too many lobbyists involved
and we have too many lawyers involved and
we should have wider representation.
Although I understand secretary of defense,
you don't necessarily want a school teacher,
although how bad could it get? Right? I mean,
I would almost consider whether a school teacher,
uh, could do as good of a job as some of the
people that are put in there. But you have
to understand that Donald Trump is, if you
believe he's draining the swamp, he's filling
it with even worse garbage. They're removing
recyclable garbage from the swamp and putting
in the stuff that won't decompose for a thousand
years. A thousand years, but, but, but in
the back of all of this, is there the possibility
that the real reason for the change in who
is going to be Donald Trump's secretary of
defense could be related to Iran policy? Is
it possible that as Tucker Carlson is advising
Trump on Iran, now I'll get to that story
later in the show. Is it possible that Trump
and Shanahan did not see eye to eye on what
Iran policy should be?
I don't know. But the real sort of true red
alert here remains, which is we still don't
have a permanent secretary of defense. The
last time this happened I believe was George
h w Bush's administration, not George W. Bush,
George H w Bush before Bill Clinton when there
was an acting secretary of defense for around
a couple of months I believe. And no permanent
one. If I'm wrong on that, I'm sure people
are going to write in and let me know.